The following episode of How We Major Mother was recorded live on Instagram on March 4th of 2026.
以下这期《How We Made Your Mother》于2026年3月4日在Instagram上进行现场直播录制。
I'm alone, would a pity I won't be soon In New York City, when I see you Please permit me to tell you everything In New York City I'm going to be here with you tonight It's eight o'clock in New York City It's five o'clock in Los Angeles where Alec is Let us know in the chat where you're tuning in from we always love to get a sense of where everyone is at the moment and we love seeing all the different places people are tuning in from.
我独自一人，不过在纽约市，当我看到你时，这种孤单感很快就会消失，请允许我对你诉说一切，今晚我将在纽约市陪伴你，纽约市现在是八点，亚历克所在的洛杉矶现在是五点，请在聊天区告诉我们你们是从哪里收听的，我们总是很想知道大家此刻都在哪里，也喜欢看到大家来自世界各地不同的地方。
You'll notice tonight I am, it's just me and Alec Craig had a bit of a family thing he has a sick kid he had to travel before and tend to.
大家会发现今晚只有我和亚历克，克雷格家里有点事，有个孩子生病了，他得提前出差去处理。
So he sends his regards.
所以他向大家致以问候。
I'll miss his delightful perspective on all things, but we're going to try to do this just me and Alec.
我会想念他对方方面面那些妙趣横生的见解，但接下来就由我和亚历克来把这场直播撑起来。
You're also, we would love to hear your questions.
此外，我们也十分期待听到大家的问题。
We're really talking, of course, mostly about how we made your mother, which is the podcast that Craig and I do, the rewatch podcast for how I met your mother.
当然，我们主要聊的还是《How We Made Your Mother》，这是我和克雷格共同主持的《老爸老妈浪漫史》重看播客。
We have finished taping all this season two episodes, but they haven't all aired yet.
我们已经完成了第二季所有剧集的录制，但并非所有剧集都已播出了。
What episode are we up to on the release?
我们目前更新到第几集了？
I believe we just released 17 or so.
我记得我们刚发布了第17集左右。
We're in the 17 era.
我们正处于17集的阶段。
Okay.
好的。
Yeah.
对。
And there's 22.
总共有22集。
We'll also be releasing these Instagram Lives.
我们也会发布这些Instagram直播的回放。
If you miss this or if a friend misses it and you want to tell them about it, they're going to be up and running on wherever you get your podcasts.
如果你错过了，或者朋友错过了你想告诉他们，它们将会在你获取播客的各大平台上架。
So Alec, help me out, what do we have in store for the folks tonight?
那么亚历克，帮我看看，今晚我们为听众们准备了什么内容？
Well, it definitely started us off by saying that already we are, we have folks coming to us from Mexico, Australia, Germany, Brazil, Sweden, Chile, Venezuela, Canada, and Brazil again.
嗯，首先要说的是，已经有来自墨西哥、澳大利亚、Germany、巴西、瑞典、智利、委内瑞拉、加拿大以及又一个来自巴西的朋友加入我们了。
Wow.
哇。
Now, someone says they're from Africa.
现在，有人说他们来自非洲。
Shout out to Brazil, I know that Brazilians like to be shouted out.
向巴西的朋友们打个招呼，我知道巴西人很喜欢被点名。
Yeah.
对。
We've now we've got Ecuador and then we've got local here.
现在我们有厄瓜多尔的，还有本地的。
We've got Chicago.
我们有芝加哥的。
We've got Kentucky.
我们有肯塔基州的。
We've got New York.
我们有纽约的。
We've got France.
我们有法国的。
It just keeps coming.
还在不断增加。
Indonesia, Peru, Portugal, Iran, Colombia.
印度尼西亚、秘鲁、葡萄牙、伊朗、哥伦比亚。
Oh my goodness gracious.
哦，天哪。
And Ohio.
还有俄亥俄州。
Ohio is finally in the house.
俄亥俄州终于加入进来了。
Well everyone, thanks for telling us where you're from.
好吧，各位，谢谢你们告诉我们你们来自哪里。
We do have Josh here ready to take your questions on all things, how I made, how I met my business, no, no, how I met and how we made your mother.
我们这里有乔希，随时准备回答你们关于“How I Made…怎么制作的”、关于“How I Met My Business”（不对，不对）、关于《老爸老妈浪漫史》以及《How We Made Your Mother》的所有问题。
While everyone is teeing up their questions, Clany Ben Venuto, well, ask, how do you feel about being part of one of the greatest shows of all time?
在大家准备问题的时候，Clany Ben Venuto问：作为有史以来最伟大的剧集之一的一部分，你有什么感觉？
Well, that's very nice.
嗯，这真是太好了。
You know, I just did Rain Wilson's podcast, Soul Boom, the other day.
你知道的，前几天我刚上了雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson）的播客节目《Soul Boom》。
And we were sharing about the weirdness and the great feeling of, you know, having been on a show, both of us on long-running iconic shows at around the same time.
我们当时在交流那种奇妙又美妙的感觉，就是我们俩大约在同一时期都出演过长盛不衰的标志性剧集。
And what's strange is like, you don't quite know you're on a show that's going to have legs until 20 years later, and people are still discovering it and talking about it and introducing it to people.
奇怪的是，你当时并不知道自己参演的是一部能经受住时间考验的剧集，直到20年过去了，人们还在不断发现它、讨论它，并把它推荐给其他人。
So at the time, you know that people like it and you know that it's working and you You keep getting renewed, which is the means the network believes in you.
所以在当时，你知道人们喜欢它，你知道它很成功，而且你的剧集不断获得续订，这意味着电视网对你们充满信心。
But we both were kind of joking that there were other shows on the air at the same time that you've probably never heard of that got a lot more press, a lot more kind of critical claim and attention than our shows.
但我们俩当时也开玩笑说，当时播出的其他一些剧集，你可能听都没听说过，它们却获得了比我们的剧集多得多的媒体报道、更多的评论界赞誉和关注。
But time has been very good to how I made your mother and the office.
但时间对《老爸老妈浪漫史》和《办公室》非常仁慈。
And shout out to the office because Jenna and Angela from the office ladies are producing us now.
在这里也要向《办公室》致敬，因为来自《Office Ladies》的珍娜（Jenna）和安吉拉（Angela）现在正在为我们担任制片人。
They came on board for season two.
她们从第二季开始加入。
So we do a lot of collaborations with them.
所以我们和她们有很多合作。
You can follow along with them because we do a lot of cross pollinating with the office ladies now.
大家也可以关注她们，因为我们现在和《Office Ladies》有很多跨界联动。
But you know what, how does it feel to be on one of the greatest shows of all time?
不过说真的，参演有史以来最伟大的剧集之一是什么感觉？
It feels really good.
感觉真的很好。
And I have a new appreciation for how great the show is since I've been doing this show and I've re-engaged with the show and watched it anew.
而且自从我开始做这个播客、重新接触这部剧并以全新的视角去观看它之后，我对这部剧究竟有多伟大有了全新的认识。
watching it with my wife who's never seen it and it's just been a blast and I'm delighted to now in a weird way become a fan of the show before I was really you know I was on it and I liked it and I appreciated it but I didn't understand on some level the enthusiasm it inspired in people until I watch it now and I'm like oh yeah I get it I get it.
我和从未看过这部剧的妻子一起看，这简直太棒了，我很欣喜自己以一种奇妙的方式成为了这部剧的粉丝；以前虽然我也参演过，我也很喜欢并欣赏它，但在某种程度上，我并不理解它在人们心中激起的热情，直到现在我重新观看它，我才心想：哦，是的，我懂了，我明白了。
Are you a fan of anything to the extent that people are fans of this show.
你对什么事物的喜爱，能达到人们喜爱这部剧的这种程度吗？
Is that another reason, maybe, why that level of fandom is hard for you to feel, is hard for you to understand, because maybe that's not quite your way of interacting with art.
这会不会是另一个原因，也许，为什么那种程度的狂热对你来说很难去感受，很难去理解，因为也许那并不是你与艺术互动的方式。
You know, I've done a few comic-ons.
你知道的，我参加过一些动漫展。
I did want an Ecuador last year.
我去年确实去过厄瓜多尔。
And I'm always touched by the enthusiasm of fans and their excitement to meet the people that they've watched and loved on screen.
我总是被粉丝们的热情以及他们见到自己在银幕上看过并喜爱的人时的兴奋所感动。
But I'm more like on the other side of things, like I'm more interested when I watch something and love something, because I create things.
但我更倾向于另一面，比如我更感兴趣的是，当我观看某样东西并喜爱它时，因为我也在创作。
I want to figure out how they did it.
我想弄清楚他们是怎么做到的。
Like I want to look under the hood of the art.
就像我想一探艺术的究竟。
Like if I love a song, I look up the chords, I figure out why the song is so affecting.
比如如果我喜欢一首歌，我会去查和弦，找出这首歌为什么那么动人。
So because I want to write my own songs, you know what I mean?
因为我想写自己的歌，你知道我的意思吗？
But I think, you know, when I was younger, there were certainly things that I was really, really in love with, but I've always thought of myself more as a creator than a fan, but to be a creator, you have to, of course, love things very deeply.
但我想，你知道的，当我更年轻的时候，确实有一些东西是我非常非常热爱的，但我一直觉得自己更像是一个创作者而不是粉丝，但要成为一个创作者，你当然必须非常深刻地热爱事物。
So there are many things that I love, but not in the way that I would dress up and go to come and home as the character.
所以有很多东西是我热爱的，但不会达到那种我会盛装打扮去动漫展扮演那个角色的程度。
Right.
对。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, you know, we've got a lot of questions coming in right now, and there are some people for whom this might be the first time they have seen you do the show live because we used to show the video for the show.
嗯，你知道的，现在有很多问题发过来，有些人这可能是他们第一次看你做现场直播的节目，因为我们以前会播放节目的视频。
We don't quite as much anymore.
现在我们不怎么放了。
And we do have a couple of people pointing something out.
确实有几个人指出了某件事。
Maybe you can tell Roxy underscore Musking Gum.
也许你可以告诉名为 Roxy_MuskingGum 的网友。
The answer to is that the real blue French horn on your bookshelf behind you.
关于“你身后书架上的那个蓝色圆号是真的吗”这个问题的答案。
Yeah, that's it.
对，就是那个。
That's the one we all got to take things from set and I think you know, some people took the jukebox or the table, you know, the bar table and I just asked for the blue French horn it felt like the best prop for me to take, you know, yeah I used to be worried that if how I met your mother fans knew that I had it that they would break into my apartment and steal it But I've let that go, but please don't is please don't We have a question here from, I'm trying to get this name here.
那是我们大家都可以从片场拿走东西的时候拿的，我想你知道，有些人拿了点唱机或者桌子，你知道的，吧台桌，而我只想要那个蓝色的圆号，我觉得对我来说这是最棒的道具，你知道的，是的，我以前还担心，如果《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的粉丝知道我有这个，他们会破门而入把我的偷走，但我已经不在乎了，不过请别偷，求你了。我们这里有个问题，我试着看一下这个名字。
Ellie Rosen-Denn, who's a fan of much of your work, and asks, what do you prefer, acting, music, or directing?
Ellie Rosen-Denn，她是你的很多作品的粉丝，她问，你更喜欢表演、音乐还是导演？
Oh, I don't know.
哦，我不知道。
I was just talking with my wife about this this morning.
我今天早上才刚和我妻子聊过这个。
I mean, I think in some ways, like, if you wanna know what's really kind of sitting on my heart or what I've been chewing on or what concerns me in the world, listen to my music.
我的意思是，我觉得在某种程度上，如果你想知道真正驻留在我心头的是什么，或者我一直在琢磨的是什么，或者这个世界上什么在困扰着我，去听我的音乐吧。
I think I'm capturing the purest essence of what I'm about and what I'm trying to say in my songs.
我觉得我在我的歌曲中捕捉到了我所代表的最纯粹的本质，以及我想要表达的东西。
And yeah, and I find myself, I don't know, I really only act when something really strikes me as I have to do that.
而且是的，我发现自己，我不知道，我真的只有在遇到某个让我觉得“我必须去做”的事情时才会去表演。
I don't think of it as a must get an acting, you know, when I was in my 20s, it was like, must get an acting job, must get an acting job.
我不认为这是一种必须去接演艺工作的心态，你知道的，当我二十多岁的时候，就像是，必须得到一份表演工作，必须得到一份表演工作。
And I don't think like that anymore.
我再也不会那样想了。
I'm going to do a play in London this summer that I really love, but I like being the conductor and the composer a little more than being the first violinist these days, but I love them all still.
我今年夏天要在伦敦演一部我很喜欢的戏剧，但如今比起当首席小提琴手，我更喜欢当乐队指挥和作曲家，不过我依然热爱它们全部。
I mean, when I get a great part to act, I still love it, but I love it in a different way.
我的意思是，当我得到一个很好的表演角色时，我依然热爱它，但我以一种不同的方式热爱它。
I don't love it in a way that it was the oxygen that I need to breathe.
我不再以它是我呼吸所需的氧气那种方式去热爱它。
That's how it used to feel.
以前感觉确实是那样。
I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这个小日子在纽约市唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now back to the show.
现在回到节目中。
Matthias Zaca asks the question that you are definitely well equipped to answer, which is how do you get into show business from the East Coast?
Matthias Zaca 提出了一个你绝对有能力回答的问题，那就是如何从东海岸进入演艺圈？
How do I get into the show?
我怎么进入演艺圈的？
How did I?
我是怎么进入的？
Oh well, how does one, I think he's interested for himself if you're not living in Los Angeles?
哦，好吧，一个人该怎么做，我想他是为自己问的，如果你不住在洛杉矶的话？
Oh, from the East Coast.
哦，从东海岸。
Okay, well, I'm from Ohio.
好吧，我是来自俄亥俄州。
I mean, I'm actually from Ohio, so it was Ted, but I'm from Columbus, so it's totally different than Cleveland.
我的意思是，我其实来自俄亥俄州，那是泰德（的故事），但我来自哥伦布，所以和克利夫兰完全不同。
How do you get into show business?
你如何进入演艺圈？
I mean, look, I got out of drama school in 1999 and it was a much different world.
我的意思是，你看，我1999年从戏剧学校毕业，那是一个非常不同的世界。
I think one of the benefits of the moment we're in right now is everyone has a phone.
我觉得我们现在身处的时代的好处之一就是每个人都有一部手机。
It's got a video component to it.
它带有视频功能。
You can edit these videos.
你可以剪辑这些视频。
You can throw them up on multiple platforms.
你可以把它们发到多个平台上。
It's so much easier to create your own content and get noticed and actually refine your style and figure out what your style is.
创作你自己的内容并获得关注，甚至提炼你的风格并弄清楚你的风格是什么，要容易得多。
I was just reading something that all these people are making horror films that they're putting up on YouTube and Hollywood is kind of like, that's where they're finding the new crop of like great horror directors.
我刚刚看到一则消息，说现在有这么多人都在拍恐怖片并上传到YouTube上，而好莱坞有点像是在那里寻找新一代的优秀恐怖片导演。
There's nothing better than proof of concept.
没有什么比概念验证更好的了。
You know, if you can show, you can go in a room and pitch a story, but if you show them the movie that you make and you show them, you've got real chops and you know how to scare people or do whatever it is you're trying to do, that's gonna be a lot better than trying to talk your way into something.
你知道的，如果你能展示，你可以走进一个房间去推销一个故事，但如果你能把拍好的电影展示给他们，向他们证明你真的有两下子，而且你知道怎么吓唬人或者完成你想做的任何事，那可比试图用嘴把项目忽悠下来好多了。
So just make things, you know, make things, get your friends together.
所以尽管去做吧，你知道的，去创作，把你的朋友们聚在一起。
The barrier to entry is lower than ever before, the cost is lower, it keeps getting lower and lower.
进入这个行业的门槛比以往任何时候都低，成本也更低，而且还在不断降低。
So it's just very different.
所以情况真的大不相同了。
There were a lot more gatekeepers when I got out of school.
我刚毕业的时候，把关的人要多得多。
You had to impress the casting director, then you had to impress, you know, first you had to get the agent, then you had to impress the casting director, then you had to impress the producers, and you had to get approved by the studio.
你得先打动选角导演，然后你还得打动，你知道的，首先你得签到经纪人，然后你得打动选角导演，接着你得打动制片人，最后还得通过制片厂的审批。
You had to prove by the network.
你还得通过电视台的批准。
There were so many hoops you had to jump through to end up on a show like How I Met Your Mother.
为了能参演像《老爸老妈浪漫史》这样的剧，你得闯过多少关卡啊。
And now it's just a different thing.
而现在情况完全不同了。
My buddies, Corey and Jeremiah, this is just a plug for them.
我的哥们科里和耶利米，这纯粹是为他们打个广告。
They created a show called Mount Mystic Park Rangers.
他们创作了一部剧叫《神秘山公园管理员》。
I think it's called, or Mount Mystic, I don't know.
我想是叫这个，或者神秘山，我记不清了。
But it's on YouTube, you can watch it now.
但它在YouTube上，你现在就能看。
It's got hundreds of thousands of views.
它有几十万的播放量。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
It's like a Parks and Rec meets office kind of mockumentary about these park rangers.
这有点像《公园与游憩》遇上《办公室》那种关于公园管理员的伪纪录片。
And they got picked up by a studio.
而且他们被一家制片厂看中了。
They're making more of them now because they're from Nashville, you know?
他们现在正在拍更多集，因为他们来自纳什维尔，你知道吗？
And now they're living in Los Angeles making a TV show.
现在他们住在洛杉矶拍电视剧。
So just make stuff.
所以尽管去创作吧。
Yeah, I feel like when what interests you is film or television, there does feel like this huge gulf between you and the ability to make the art you want to make, which is so different from being a singer-songwriter with your guitar on your stool or a painter.
是的，我觉得当你的兴趣是电影或电视时，你确实会觉得你和创作你想制作的艺术之间存在一条巨大的鸿沟，这和那些抱着吉他坐在高脚凳上的唱作人或者画家截然不同。
And yeah, I mean the joy of gathering up your friends of gathering up your friends in the bar and saying, I'm going to make this thing.
是的，我是说，把你的朋友们聚集在酒吧里，说“我要拍这个东西”，这种感觉本身就是一种快乐。
And it's hard, there's something hard inside you that goes, but wait a second, this isn't a real movie because this studio that's owned by a company that makes washing machines is not making my movie, so it's not real, there are an advertisement up on Billboard, so it's not real.
这很难，你内心深处会有某种声音在说：“但等一下，这不是一部真正的电影，因为这家被制造洗衣机的公司所拥有的制片厂没有拍我的电影，所以它不是真的，也没有在巨型广告牌上打广告，所以它不是真的。”
And that's an internal thing I've had to get over and people have to get over to say, no, no, I made a movie from start to finish.
这是我不得不克服的内心障碍，也是大家必须克服的心理，我们要对自己说：“不，不，我从头到尾制作了一部电影。”
That's a movie.
这就是一部电影。
I can't really control one outcome.
我无法真正控制某一种结果。
If there's something about, it's a screen and it literally feels like a screen, like how do you get in there?
如果有什么特别之处，那就是它是一个屏幕，而且感觉真像是一个屏幕，比如你怎么才能进到里面去？
How do you get into that screen?
你怎么才能进到那个屏幕里？
It feels like so far, like the golf, the chasm.
感觉太远了，就像那条沟壑，那道深渊。
Whereas if you go to the theater, you go see stand up, you go see a musician, There are a couple feet from you, maybe, depending on how good your ticket is.
然而如果你去剧院，去看脱口秀，去看音乐演出，他们离你只有几英尺远，也许吧，这取决于你的票有多好。
And you can see like, oh, they're up on stage and I know that's hard to get up, but it almost feels easier than a screen to navigate that or get there.
你可以看到，哦，他们就在舞台上，我知道要站上去不容易，但比起银幕，要克服这种距离或到达那里，感觉似乎更容易一些。
But there's no substitution for doing it and failing.
但动手去做并经历失败是无可替代的。
I actually heard Quentin Tarantino, big how I made your mother fan, Quentin Tarantino, not a lot of people know this.
我其实听说昆汀·塔伦蒂诺——很多人不知道这一点——其实是个《老爸老妈浪漫史》的超级大粉丝。
And I don't think this is apocryphal, maybe can someone can fact check this, but that he actually directed a movie before Reservoir Dogs.
而且我觉得这并非道听途说，也许有人可以核实一下，他在《落水狗》之前其实导演过一部电影。
That Reservoir Dogs wasn't his first movie, but he directed a very low-budget movie and he said he got all of his mistakes out of his.
《落水狗》并不是他的第一部电影，但他导演过一部预算极低的电影，他说他把所有的错误都在那部片里犯光了。
So he just made tons of mistakes.
所以他犯了成吨的错误。
And by the time he got to Reservoir Dogs, he had enough wherewithal to know how to delegate and figure it out.
等到他拍《落水狗》的时候，他已经有了足够的经验和头脑去懂得如何授权和解决问题。
So he avoided a lot of the potholes that he fell into the first movie.
所以他避开了他在第一部电影中踩过的许多大坑。
But you've got to go out and get your mistakes in.
但你必须亲自去把错误都犯一遍。
Yeah.
是的。
You have to.
你必须这么做。
you'll learn so much from just doing.
你从实践中能学到太多东西。
Yeah, and also I think the size of the movie or the TV show, it feels a little, you know, you see that there's a, I mean, how I met your mother, I had 120 people or whatever it was that made that thing.
是的，而且我觉得电影或电视剧的规模，感觉有点，你知道的，你看到有一个，我是说，《老爸老妈浪漫史》，我有120个人或者无论多少人共同打造了那个东西。
And you watch the credits of your average movie.
你看普通电影的演职员表。
It just goes on and on and on.
就是没完没了地滚动。
And you feel like, oh, well, I only had like three guys help me make my little thing, so it's not real.
你会觉得，哦，好吧，我只有三个人帮我做我的小东西，所以它不是真的。
But you just gotta get over that.
但你必须要克服这种心态。
And something that I just finished making, just finished post production.
我最近刚做完的一部作品，刚刚完成后期制作。
In the credits, I wrote the 11 people who made this movie.
在职员表里，我写上了制作这部电影的11个人的名字。
And then there's the credits that run for about seven seconds, and you have a quick list of people that did it.
然后演职员表只滚动大约七秒钟，上面快速列出了参与制作的人员名单。
And even with me, I have to get over the feeling of like, so is it a real movie?
即使是我，我也得克服那种感觉，比如：这真的是一部电影吗？
Is it a real movie?
这真的是一部电影吗？
And it is, there's nothing else that it is.
它确实是，它不可能是什么别的东西。
I never worry about that.
我从不为此担心。
I post something on me singing a song, and I'm like, this is a real, this is a real video.
我发布一段自己唱歌的视频，我就会觉得，这是真的，这是一个真实的视频。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
对，对，对，好吧。
So, what, alley.gorman22?
那么，什么，alley.gorman22？
I believe that Ali has asked some questions before.
我相信阿里以前也问过一些问题。
What is one of your favorite pieces of advice that stuck with you that was given from one of the characters on the show?
剧中某个角色给过你的、一直伴随着你并且你最喜欢的建议之一是什么？
Oh my God, what a great question.
天哪，多么棒的问题。
Well, I've been getting reminded of so much great advice.
嗯，我一直被提醒想起那么多极好的建议。
I mean, I think, what is it like, what is that line?
我是说，我觉得，那是什么台词？
It's very motivational, like, if you're not going for it, if you're not trying, then what the hell are you doing?
非常具有激励性，比如，如果你不去争取，如果你不去尝试，那你到底在干什么鬼？
Like, if you're not risking, is there something, like, someone will write it in the comments.
就像，如果你不去冒险，是不是有什么，等下有人会在评论区写出来的。
It's something that maybe the narrator says, like, if you're not taking a chance, something like that.
大概是旁白说的那种话，比如，如果你不抓住机会，诸如此类的话。
And it's about like risk and courage.
这关乎风险和勇气。
I mean, there, I really think how I met your mother has like some timeless, wonderful wisdom to it.
我是说，真的，我觉得《老爸老妈浪漫史》里有一些永恒而美妙的人生智慧。
Nothing good happens after 2 a.m.
“凌晨两点以后没有好事发生”
is like perennially great advice.
简直就是永不过时的伟大建议。
Love is the best thing we do.
爱是我们做过最好的事。
I'm trying to think like other maybe maybe people could put in the comments like what are their favorite bits of advice.
我在想别的，也许大家可以在评论区写下他们最喜欢的建议是什么。
While we're waiting for that, Kevin Aang05 asks if you play video games and if so what is your favorite?
在我们等待的时候，Kevin Aang05问你玩不玩电子游戏，如果玩的话你最喜欢哪一个？
I don't I mean I did a little I did when I was a kid but But I am not what one would call a game, is that what they call it?
我不——我是说，我以前玩过一点，我小时候玩过，但我不是那种会被称为游戏玩家的人，是这么叫的吗？
But I'm a word game person, so I do, I'm a wordle, crossword, spelling bee is actually my favorite, New York Times app, so those are my game diversions daily.
但我喜欢文字游戏，所以我玩，我是Wordle、纵横字谜、拼写蜜蜂游戏的铁粉，事实上这是我最喜欢的纽约时报应用里的游戏，所以这些是我每天消遣的游戏。
What is, no, from what you've, oh, oh, you'll love this, okay, so Ashley, Channek, Chansek, It says, from what you've re-watched so far, I mean, I think a big thing that you guys have been talking about is the music on the show, and that it is, there's so much that makes how I met your mother unique, but certainly no network show has ever mined music the way this has, from what you've watched so far, so seasons one and two, what has been your favorite song that they have included in a scene?
有什么——不，从你——哦，哦，你一定会喜欢这个，好的，所以Ashley, Channek, Chansek说，从你目前重温的剧集来看——我是说，我觉得你们一直在讨论的一个大问题是剧中的音乐，而且确实有太多东西让《老爸老妈浪漫史》与众不同，但肯定没有任何一部电视网剧集像这部剧这样对音乐进行过如此深入的发掘——从你目前看过的部分来看，也就是第一季和第二季，他们包含在场景中的歌曲里，你最喜欢哪一首？
Well, in return of this shirt, episode four of season one, I think it was, it, a big part of it is this Bell and Sebastian song.
嗯，在第一季第四集《衬衫的回归》里，我想是的，其中很大一部分是这首贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安（Bell and Sebastian）的歌。
Was it, we rule the school?
是《我们统治学校》吗？
I can't remember.
我记不清了。
But it was from Tiger milk, I think their first record.
但它是从《虎乳》那张专辑来的，我想那是他们的第一张唱片。
I love Bell and Sebastian.
我超爱贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安。
So when I got that script, I was like, I can't believe I'm on a sitcom on CBS that is like featuring this Scottish indie band, this great song, but Carter and Craig and I had a lot of musical overlaps.
所以当我拿到那个剧本时，我想，真不敢相信我竟然在CBS的一部情景喜剧里，里面居然有这支苏格兰独立乐队的歌，这首美妙的歌，不过卡特、克雷格和我有很多重合的音乐品味。
I mean, they introduced me like I wasn't a big one.
我是说，他们把我引入了——我以前对The Replacements乐队不是很了解。
I wasn't big into the replacements and they got me into the replacements.
我不是很了解The Replacements，是他们带我了解的。
I introduced them to a lot of songwriters, both some of whom I knew, but a lot of them I just like loved their songs.
我向他们介绍了很多词曲创作者，其中有些人我认识，但很多人我只是单纯喜欢他们的歌。
They ended up on the show.
这些歌最后都出现在了剧里。
I actually, I mean, I hope he doesn't mind me saying this.
我甚至——我是说，我希望我说这话他不介意。
I introduced Jason to to balance Sebastian's Get Me Away From Here I'm Dying, which ended up in Forgetting Sarah Marshall, because he flipped for that song so much.
我向杰森推荐了贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安的《把我从这里带走，我快死了》，这首歌最后出现在了《忘掉莎拉·马歇尔》里，因为他太迷这首歌了。
That's one of those things, it's like a weird brag where you're like, I introduced him to a song.
这就是那种事情，就像一种奇怪的炫耀，你会觉得：我向他推荐了一首歌。
He put in a movie, but it was really well used in the movie and I remember, because I used to burn CDs for the cast because I was like the music guy on set.
他把它放进了一部电影里，而且它在电影里用得真的很好，我记得，因为我过去经常为剧组刻录CD，因为我是片场负责音乐的那个人。
But I also in the episode where it was like, Was it moving or like where Robin had the five dogs and they all turned into her boyfriends?
不过在有一集里——是搬家那一集吗？还是罗宾养了五只狗，后来它们都变成了她的男朋友的那一集？
Right, right.
对，对。
Moving day?
《搬家日》？
Yeah, moving day.
对，搬家日。
They used an Iggy pop song or maybe it was Stooges called I Wanna Be Your Dog.
他们用了一首伊基·波普的歌，或者也许是The Stooges乐队的歌，叫做《我想成为你的狗》。
I think it was called I Wanna Be Your Dog, which is all about like S&M.
我想它叫《我想成你的狗》，这首歌完全是关于SM（虐恋）的。
But in the show it becomes quite literal, I wanna be your dog.
但在剧中它变得非常字面意思，我想成为你的狗。
And I thought that was such a funny needle drop.
我觉得那个音乐切入点太搞笑了。
That was a really good one.
那真是一个非常棒的插曲。
Got it past the sensors.
成功避开了传感器。
We have a couple of people who wait in on your attempt to put together one of those quotes.
我们有几个人一直在等你整理那些语录。
One says, Anna, Anam, C, says, if you don't try, you won't win.
其中一个说，安娜，Anam C，说，不尝试你就不会赢。
No, that wasn't the one.
不对，不是那个。
Okay, then Emmanuel, Larry, O, says, if you're not scared, you're not taking a chance, if you're not taking a chance, then what the hell are you doing?
好吧，那伊曼纽尔·拉里·O（Emmanuel Larry O）说，如果你不害怕，你就是在冒险，如果你不冒险，那他妈的你在干什么？
If you're not scared, you're not taking a chance and you're not taking a chance on what the hell are you doing?
如果你不害怕，你就是在冒险，而如果不冒险，你他妈的到底在干什么？
That's the one.
就是这个。
I think that's great.
我觉得这太棒了。
I think that's great advice.
我觉得这是个绝佳的建议。
And I have found it's true like I had an acting teacher at NYU who used to say, fear is just excitement without breath.
我发现这确实如此，就像我在纽约大学的一位表演老师过去常说的，恐惧只是没有呼吸的兴奋。
You realize you're holding your breath.
你意识到自己一直在屏住呼吸。
You're actually excited.
其实你很兴奋。
New things are so scary.
新鲜事物总是那么让人害怕。
I heard it described this way by a meditation teacher that our brains are like accountants.
我听一位冥想老师这样描述过：我们的大脑就像会计师。
They can only tell you where you've been.
它们只能告诉你你去过哪里。
They sift through the receipts and they tell you where you've been.
它们梳理着收据，然后告诉你你到过何方。
So your brain actually wants you to repeat the things it has done, you've already done, and it's catalogued and deemed safe.
所以你的大脑其实希望你重复那些它已经做过、你已经做过、并且被它归档认定为安全的事情。
But all the gold in life is in risk and newness and adventure and taking a leap, right?
但生活中的所有黄金都在于冒险、尝新、历险和奋力一跃，对吧？
But your brain is always gonna say, are you sure about that?
但你的大脑总是会说，你确定吗？
I don't have receipts for that.
我可没有那方面的收据。
I don't know when that's like, maybe we shouldn't do it.
我不知道那算什么，也许我们不该去做。
But it's, you got a leap frog, you know, pole vault or whatever over that part of your brain.
但你得跨栏，你知道的，撑竿跳或者用别的方法越过大脑的那一部分。
Sometimes if your brain is like, I think that looks unsafe.
有时如果你的大脑觉得，这看起来不安全。
Like maybe pay attention, like you don't want to put yourself in grave danger, but also your brain will respond as if it's grave danger when it's just like a social invitation.
就像或许该注意点，你不想让自己陷入极度危险之中，但同时，你的大脑在面对仅仅是一场社交邀请时，也会表现得好像面临弥天大祸一样。
You're scared to go to the party or whatever, you know.
你害怕去参加派对什么的，你知道的。
But yeah, if you're not scared, you're not taking a chance.
但没错，如果你不害怕，你就是在冒险。
If you're not taking a chance of what the hell you're doing, I like that I'm gonna stick with that one.
如果你不冒险，你他妈的到底在干什么，我喜欢这个，我就选这个了。
Gillie NZ underscore 83 says two part question.
Gillie NZ underscore 83 提出了一个两部分的问题。
Who was the guest star that made you fangirl out the most?
哪个客串明星最让你秒变狂热粉丝？
And who do you remember killed at the most as a guest star?
你觉得哪个客串明星作为嘉宾表现得最惊艳？
I remember being very delighted that Martin Short was a guest star on the show.
我记得马丁·肖特（Martin Short）来剧里客串时，我感到非常高兴。
And I remember, am I still coming through here, Alec?
而且我记得，艾利克，我的声音还能传过来吗？
Yeah, you're good.
对，没问题。
Yeah.
对。
Martin Short also, I think I don't remember what season it was.
马丁·肖特也是，我想不起来是哪一季了。
It was a later season, but there's real bloopers of him making me, in particular, laugh.
那是后来的某一季，有他逗得我尤其是哈哈大笑的真实NG花絮。
He seemed to delight in the anarchy of, you know, getting people to break.
他似乎很享受那种混乱感，你知道的，总想让人笑场。
I, yeah, I loved Martin Short.
我，是的，我很喜欢马丁·肖特。
Who else was, I mean, it was really fun when Tim Gunn was there.
还有谁来着，我是说，蒂姆·古恩（Tim Gunn）来的时候真的很有趣。
But also, Tim Gunn and I have the same birthday, and he knew that.
而且，蒂姆·古恩和我同一天生日，他知道这一点。
he like came up to set with that fact.
他带着这个事实来到片场。
He was like, July 29th, he's like me and you.
他当时说，7月29日，我和你一样。
And I'm trying to think, I mean, there were a couple other, like Franny Conroy who played Barney's mom, Edward Herman, like sometimes they were just like great New York theater actors that I knew that were legends in the New York theater that maybe the people out in the world don't know as well, but they were really thrilling to me.
我在想要不要提，我是说，还有其他一些人，比如饰演巴尼妈妈的弗兰西斯·康罗伊（Franny Conroy）、爱德华·赫曼（Edward Herman），有时他们只是一些我认识的伟大的纽约戏剧演员，是纽约戏剧界的传奇人物，也许外界的人对他们不太熟悉，但他们对我来说真的超级激动人心。
And then you just get to know people and you really like them.
然后你慢慢了解了这些人，你会真的很喜欢他们。
I like Chris Ellie.
我喜欢克里斯·埃利奥特（Chris Elliott）。
It's a great guy and You know, there were there was just so many guest stars.
他是个好人，而且，你知道的，有那么多的客串明星。
It's hard to think of them all right now now Ami DWV asks a question that gives us a great moment to kind of promote our own show here who asks are you still in touch with Kobe?
现在很难把他们都想起来了，Ami DWV 问了一个问题，这给了我们一个宣传自己节目的绝佳契机，她问，你现在还和寇碧（Cobie）保持联系吗？
Yes for sure, but Mostly Well, she's been on this show.
是的，当然，但主要是，好吧，她上过这个节目。
She's been on the podcast.
她上过这个播客。
Yeah So we got to reminisce in a really sweet way.
是的，所以我们以一种非常温馨的方式一起追忆了过去。
But I also send her the occasional picture of my baby, which she loves seeing.
但我也偶尔会给她发一张我宝宝的照片，她很喜欢看。
Yeah, let's make sure that everyone listening here knows we have a podcast and this is part of that podcast and still some people I know who are fans of yours, follow you on Instagram, still are new to that.
是的，我们要确保这里听节目的每个人都知道我们有一个播客，这也是该播客的一部分，而且我认识的一些喜欢你、在Instagram上关注你的粉丝，对这个节目还是新面孔。
Do you want to just give a quick, the quick success?
你要不要简单介绍一下？
Yeah, it's called how we made your mother.
好，节目叫《我们是如何创造你母亲的》（How We Made Your Mother）。
It's me and Craig Thomas.
我和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）一起主持。
Craig is a co-creator of How I Mate and Mother with Carter Bayes.
克雷格是《老爸老妈浪漫史》（How I Met Your Mother）与卡特·贝伊斯（Carter Bays）共同创剧人。
Craig and I are going episode by episode, talking about the show, talking about what it was like to make it, answering all your questions about how we made the show, quite literally how we made the show.
我和克雷格一集一集地回顾这部剧，聊聊这部剧，聊聊拍摄时的感受，回答大家关于我们是如何制作这部剧的所有问题，字面意思上我们是如何制作这部剧的。
And also, we're exploring from this vantage point of being 12 years after the show ended, 19 years after it premiered, why the show has had such staying power, why it continues to mint new fans every single year.
同时，我们站在节目结束12年后、开播19年后的这个视角，探讨为什么这部剧能有如此持久的生命力，为什么它每年都能吸引源源不断的新粉丝。
What is it about the special mystery and magic of the show that keeps people coming back to it, quoting it, wanting it to live, and wanting to live inside of it, and how it helps people through dark times.
究竟是什么特殊的神秘感和魔力让人们不断回看它、引用它的台词、希望它继续延续、想要置身于它的世界里，以及它是如何帮助人们度过黑暗时期的。
We start every episode with a voice note we get from a fan, so if you, and also we end the show with a written letter from fans.
我们在每一集的开头都会播放一条来自粉丝的语音留言，如果你们想，而且我们还会在节目结尾朗读来自粉丝的信件。
So if you would like to tell us what how I made your mother means to you, please go to how we made your mother.com, H-W-M-Y-N also works, I think.com.
所以如果你想告诉我们《我们育成了你的母亲》（How I Made Your Mother）对你意味着什么，请访问 howwemedyourmother.com，HWMYN 也可以，我想.com 结尾就行。
How we made your mother.com go to contact and it's pretty simple how to follow those directions.
howwemedyourmother.com，点击联系页面，按照上面的说明操作非常简单。
But we'd love to hear from you.
不过我们很想听到你们的声音。
It's our favorite thing about the show is to hear from you all.
了解你们大家的想法是我们做这个节目最喜欢的部分。
So yeah, that's what's been going on on the podcast front.
所以，这就是播客这边的情况。
And on the non-podcast front, Patrick 2-2-1-1-8-2 would like to know, did it mean a lot to you starring in Hunters considering its themes?
在非播客方面，帕特里克 2-2-1-1-8-2 想知道，考虑到《猎人》（Hunters）的主题，在其中主演对你来说意义重大吗？
Yes, I mean, I loved doing it just because I've played a lot of characters like Ted who are, I would call them like the virtuous center of the show, you know, like the character through which the audience enters in, the eyes and ears for the audience.
是的，我是说，我喜欢参演，只是因为我演过很多像泰德这样的角色，我会称他们为节目的美德核心，你知道的，也就是观众借以进入剧情的角色，是观众的耳目。
And I like playing those characters, and I've gotten good at playing those characters, but I always would get a little jealous of the characters who were a little more broad and a little more ridiculous, and had maybe less screen time, but came in, chewed the scenery, stole the scene, and then got the hell out.
我喜欢扮演这些角色，我也擅长扮演这些角色，但我总是会有点嫉妒那些戏路更宽、更荒诞、戏份可能少一些，但一出场就抢尽风头、大飙演技，然后麻溜滚蛋的角色。
And on Hunters, I played this character Lonnie Flash, who was this incredibly arrogant, insecure, 1970s, movie star, drug addict, in and out of recovery.
而在《猎人》中，我饰演了罗尼·弗拉什（Lonnie Flash）这个角色，他是一个极其傲慢、缺乏安全感、20世纪70年代的电影明星、瘾君子，戒毒戒了又犯。
And he was ridiculous and pompous and funny and ultimately heartbreaking.
他荒谬、自负、搞笑，最终又让人心碎。
And I felt like I got to do more of a broad side character.
我觉得我尝试扮演了一个更多面、更宽泛的配角。
But it was so much fun.
但真的太有趣了。
And the cast was delightful.
而且演员阵容也很讨喜。
I'm still really tight with them.
我和他们的关系至今仍然非常好。
And, you know, we got to shoot in Prague.
而且，你知道的，我们去布拉格拍摄了。
It felt like the closest I'll get to doing a James Bond movie or something.
感觉这是我离拍詹姆斯·邦德电影或类似作品最近的一次了。
It was really, it was like international intrigue.
真的很有国际谍战的氛围。
And, you know, it was about hunting Nazis and about anti-Semitism.
而且，你知道的，这是关于猎杀纳粹和反犹太主义的。
And so, yeah, it was very meaningful to me, both just personally and professionally.
所以，是的，无论是在个人还是专业层面上，这对我来说都意义重大。
I love that job.
我太喜欢那份工作了。
And I just, I think it just went on Netflix.
而且我觉得它刚刚在Netflix上线了。
So if you haven't seen Hunters, it's a great show.
所以如果你还没看过《猎人》，这是一部很棒的剧。
We're just going to bounce back to music for one second.
我们马上切回音乐话题。
Bianca Aleini wants to know if you have a favorite music artist right now, who you're into right now.
比安卡·阿莱尼（Bianca Aleini）想知道你现在有没有最喜欢的音乐艺术家，你最近在听谁的歌。
I'm really into this instrumental pianist named Phil Cook.
我最近迷上了一位名叫菲尔·库克（Phil Cook）的器乐钢琴家。
He's amazing if you want just like, like, I like to listen to a lot of instrumental music when I, when I write.
如果你只想听……就像我写作时喜欢听很多纯音乐一样，他弹得太棒了。
So I don't like to have lyrics.
所以我不太喜欢有歌词的。
I just discovered, I love Joni Mitchell, but I had never known her song cactus tree, which is like fast becoming my favorite Joni Mitchell song.
我最近刚发现，我很喜欢琼尼·米歇尔（Joni Mitchell），但我以前从未听过她的歌《仙人掌树》（Cactus Tree），这首歌正迅速成为我最喜欢的琼尼·米歇尔的歌。
My son also really loves Van Morrison for some reason.
我儿子不知为什么也很喜欢范·莫里森（Van Morrison）。
When we put on Van Morrison, he chills out.
当我们播放范·莫里森的歌时，他就会安静下来。
So, I've been listening to a lot of Anne Morrison, I'm trying to, I'm looking through.
所以，我一直在听很多范·莫里森的歌，我正在试着，我正在翻看。
Oh, you know it's a really good album.
哦，你知道有一张非常棒的专辑吗？
This Hannah Cohen album that came out this past year is, it's got a four thing name.
汉娜·科恩（Hannah Cohen）过去这一年发行的这张专辑，它的名字有四个字。
Earth Star Mountain, Hannah Cohen, great record.
《地球之星山》（Earth Star Mountain），汉娜·科恩，一张伟大的唱片。
If you like Fleetwood Mac, you'll really like that.
如果你喜欢佛利伍麦克（Fleetwood Mac），你一定会喜欢这张。
And the companion question from Maddick Stevens, what's your favorite book right now?
来自马迪克·史蒂文斯（Maddick Stevens）的配套问题，你现在最喜欢哪本书？
I'm reading a bunch of books.
我正在读好几本书。
I am reading Susan Cain's book Bittersweet, which is beautiful.
我正在读苏珊·凯恩（Susan Cain）的书《苦甜参半》（Bittersweet），非常优美。
I'm reading Karen Armstrong's biography of the Prophet Muhammad.
我正在读凯伦·阿姆斯特朗（Karen Armstrong）写的《先知穆罕默德传》（Prophet Muhammad）。
I know a bunch about Sufiism, but I didn't, I realized I didn't know that much about Islam And this book was recommended to me, and it's biography of the Prophet Muhammad, and I think it's wonderful.
我对苏菲主义了解不少，但我以前不知道，我意识到自己对伊斯兰教了解得其实没那么多，这本书是别人推荐给我的，它是关于先知穆罕默德的传记，我觉得它棒极了。
And then I'm reading Kieran Desai's novel, The Loneliness of Sonia and Sunny, which is also very beautiful.
然后我在读基兰·德赛的小说《索尼娅和桑尼的孤独》，也非常好看。
So I've got three really good books.
所以我手头有三本非常棒的书。
I do that, I read a lot of books at once.
我经常这样，同时读很多书。
But yeah.
不过是的。
Yeah, yeah.
对，没错。
This is one, it's always, I'm not sure if there's a way to answer this, because there's a bit of a, I don't know if the right word, but sometimes you don't talk about this exactly, but Kevin Aang says, have you ever regretted not accepting a role?
这是一个……总觉得，我不知道怎么回答，因为这里面有点……我不知道用这个词对不对，但有时你不会具体聊这个，不过凯文·昂（Kevin Aang）问：你有没有后悔过拒绝某个角色？
Yes.
有。
Okay.
好吧。
Do we leave it at that?
我们就这么算了吗？
Yes.
是的。
I have two or three that kind of haunt me a little bit.
我有两三个角色至今让我有点念念不忘。
But I will say this, I won't say what they are.
但我得说，我不会说是哪几个。
Because someone else played those roles and they played them well.
因为别人演了这些角色，而且演得很好。
And I don't think it helps anyone to know that they got it, that they came to me first.
我觉得让别人知道他们拿到了这个角色、而且是先找的我，对任何人都没有帮助。
Like, that doesn't help anyone.
就这真的对谁都没好处。
So, you know, there was one right after how I met your mother that really wanted, they offered it to me twice, they really wanted me.
所以呢，你知道的，就在《老爸老妈浪漫史》之后有一个项目，他们真的很想让我演，找了我两次，他们真的很想要我。
And it became quite a wonderful and honored show, but I needed time away from series television.
后来那部剧成了一部非常棒且备受赞誉的剧，但我当时需要从连续剧电视节目中抽身出来休息。
Like I just couldn't see going directly into another series.
我就是觉得自己没办法直接接着拍另一部剧。
But, you know, then I went to New York, I did a play on Broadway, I, you know, There are experiences I had that I would not have had otherwise that I can't imagine, you know, not knowing certain people are having had those experiences.
不过，你知道的，后来我去了纽约，在百老汇演了一部话剧，我……你知道的，我经历了一些如果没有那些经历就不会有的事情，我无法想象自己会不知道某些人或者没有过那些经历。
So.
所以。
Right.
对。
As your re-watching asks, oh, Ashley, again, hi, Ashley, John, and Zach, have there been scenes that you realize you don't remember filming at all?
正如你的重看环节所问的，哦，阿什利，再次你好，阿什利、约翰和扎克，有没有哪些场景是你发现自己完全不记得当时是怎么拍的了？
100% 100% is that is that and in terms of percentages, what percentage do you not remember?
百分之百。百分之百，真的吗，那从比例上来说，你不记得的占百分之多少？
Oh, it's small.
哦，比例很小。
I would say it's under 10% that I don't remember.
我可以说不记得的不到10%。
I mean, I might not remember the actual filming day or what was going on, but I remember the scene, you know, because by the time you shoot them, you've read them and rehearsed them six, seven, 10 times, you know, so they get pretty ingrained.
我是说，我可能不记得具体的拍摄那天发生了什么，但我记得那个场景，你知道的，因为等你拍的时候，你已经读过、排练过六次、七次、十次了，所以它们已经深深印在脑子里了。
But there was a scene, I think it was one of the Brian Cranston episodes where there was an older guy who was like the head of the head of the company.
但有一个场景，我想是布莱恩·克兰斯顿（Brian Cranston）客串的那几集之一，里面有一个老头，好像是公司的负责人。
Yep, yep.
对，对。
And I had to talk to him, and I remember saying on the podcast to Craig, and it really made me laugh.
我得跟他说话，我记得在播客里对克雷格说过，这真的让我大笑。
The scene made me laugh.
那个场景让我笑个不停。
Both of us, the old guy in me made me laugh.
我们俩，那个老头和我，让我笑得很开心。
And I was like, I told him, I say, I have no memory of filming this, zero.
我当时就对他说，我说，我完全不记得拍过这个，一点记忆都没有。
And I was delighted that it was there.
而且我很高兴它被拍下来了。
I mean, it's like finding a, I don't know, it's almost like someone videotaped you when you were a blackout drunk.
我的意思是，这就像是找到了一段……我不知道，这几乎就像有人在你喝到断片不省人事的时候把你拍成了录像。
You're like, oh my God, no memory.
你会觉得，天哪，完全没记忆。
Yeah.
对。
I wasn't blackout drunk, by the way, on that day.
顺便说一句，那天我可没有喝到断片。
Not that day.
不是那天。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, knew we were York City.
然后这个老头，他……我爱上了你，知道我们当时在纽约市。
And now, commercials!
现在进入广告时间！
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼（Alex Goldman），《Hyper-Fixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会倾听听众的烦恼并试着帮他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我都30岁了，却还不敢在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我的车在倒车时，无法调节车载音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
You have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
只要你有一个问题，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的背后隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《Hyper-Fixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at hyperfixedpod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台找到我们，或者访问 hyperfixedpod.com。
End of commercials?
广告结束了吗？
Back to Shell.
回到节目。
By the way, underscore hello, underscore.
顺便说一句，下划线hello下划线。
A key says, I didn't know this was reposted today.
A key说，我不知道今天是重播。
Maybe you know that Selena Gomez posted a fan mama with you, Josh, on her story today.
也许你知道赛琳娜·戈麦斯（Selena Gomez）今天在她的快拍里发了一张和你有关的粉丝萌图，乔什。
I saw.
我看到了。
Yeah, and the question is, Oh, the question is, how was your experience when other people praise you, the cast and the show?
对，然后问题是，哦，问题是，当别人赞美你、赞美演员和这部剧时，你的感受是怎样的？
Well, let me just say this.
好吧，我先这么说吧。
I did see, Selena and I met at a party and she approached, she started talking to me, we were taking the elevator down at the same time.
我的确看到了，我和赛琳娜是在一个派对上认识的，她走过来开始跟我说话，我们当时正好一起坐电梯下楼。
And so we had a really funny, sweet moment and took this picture and she had posted it once before.
所以我们有了一个非常有趣、温馨的时刻，拍了这张照片，她以前也发过一次。
And I'm gonna reach out to her, but I would just, if she happens to be listening, we would love to have Selena Gomez on how we made your mother.
我要联系她，但如果她刚好在听的话，我们真的很希望能邀请赛琳娜·戈麦斯来上《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
because she's a huge how I met your mother fan.
因为她是个超级《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝。
She posts about it there.
她经常在上面发相关的内容。
She even just posts kind of random pictures where it's just on in the background.
她甚至会发一些随意的照片，背景里正播着这部剧。
I just think it's a show she keeps going.
我觉得这就是一部她一直在追的剧。
So Selena, if you're listening, I'm gonna reach out, but we would love to have you to talk to you about your love of the show and why you love it so much.
所以赛琳娜，如果你在听的话，我会去联系你的，但我们非常希望你能来聊聊你对这部剧的喜爱以及为什么这么喜欢它。
We won't take it too much of your time.
我们不会占用你太多时间的。
But the question was, what is it like when people praise you, praise me where the show are you?
但问题是，当人们赞美你、赞美我和这部剧时，那是一种什么样的体验？
Can you take that?
你能接受吗？
can move ahead, and how has that changed over your life?
可以继续，这随着你的生活发生了怎样的变化？
Cause I know it's very different in your twenties and thirties than in the forties and thirties.
因为我知道你在二十多岁和三十多岁时的感受，跟四十多岁时是非常不同的。
That's such a great, thoughtful question.
这是一个非常棒、很有深度的问题。
You know, sometimes it's really hard to, except praise, like, I, how I met your mother, Jordana and my wife pointed out that when people come up to me and want to talk about how I met your mother, because we've been together four years and she said, since this podcast has been on, there's been a notable shift in how warm you are to how I met your mother fans who come up and want to talk to you about the show because I think I understand their enthusiasm more.
你知道的，有时候真的很难接受赞美，就像……《老爸老妈浪漫史》，乔丹娜和我的妻子指出，当人们走过来想跟我聊《老爸老妈浪漫史》时——因为我们已经在一起四年了，她说自从这个播客开播以来，我对那些走过来想找我聊这部剧的《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝的态度有了一个明显的转变，变得温暖多了，因为我觉得我更能理解他们的热情了。
And it's like I've become a fan too, so I can share it more, more than feeling like I'm being kind of pinned against the wall or made to be some sort of zoo animal or something.
这就好像我也成了一个粉丝，所以我可以更多地去分享这份热情，而不是觉得像被逼到墙角或者被当成某种动物园里的动物一样。
But so that's really been helpful.
所以这真的很有帮助。
But my relationship to praise has gone through a lot of changes because I'm from the Midwest and I know people in Australia kind of deal with this where it's like, don't brag, don't act like you're better than anyone else.
不过我和赞美之间的关系经历了很多变化，因为我来自中西部，我知道在澳大利亚的人也有这种感觉，那就是：不要吹牛，不要表现得自己比任何人都优秀。
So I was very self-effacing the word.
所以我以前总是非常谦逊，就是那个词。
Like I was very, I would dodge compliments.
我以前总是会躲避赞美。
I knew, but I was also like starving for external validation and wanting people to tell me I was good and talented and charming and wonderful.
我知道，但与此同时我也极度渴望外界的认可，希望别人告诉我我很优秀、很有才华、很有魅力、非常棒。
But I really struggled with it.
但我真的很挣扎。
And I had a very wise mentor figure who told me I needed to get over that and I needed to accept that I was good and talented and that if I didn't take an honest assessment of my own gifts, I wouldn't get where I needed to be in this life and this business, because he said every time he would compliment me, I would kind of run away.
我曾有一位非常明智的导师人物，他告诉我，我必须克服这一点，必须接受自己确实很优秀、很有才华，如果我不对自己的天赋做出诚实的评估，我就无法在这个生活和这个行业中达到我应有的高度，因为他说每次他夸我的时候，我都会像逃跑一样。
I would dodge them, I wouldn't take it.
我会躲开赞美，不去接受它。
So I think there's an art to accepting a compliment, because essentially when someone says, your work really moved me, or I really like that thing you made, If you say no, no, no, no, or run away or swat it away, you're actually telling them they have bad taste.
所以我认为接受赞美也是一门艺术，因为本质上当别人说“你的作品真的打动了我”或者“我真的很喜欢你做的那个东西”时，如果你说“不不不不”或者逃跑、把赞美推开，你实际上是在告诉他们他们的品味很差。
Like you're being cruel to someone who is extending themselves and being kind.
这就好比你在对一个向你敞开心扉、释放善意的人表现得很刻薄。
So I really try to work at being a gracious acceptor of compliments because I believe most people are sincere when they're saying something.
所以我真的很努力地让自己成为一个优雅地接受赞美的人，因为我相信大多数人在说某些话时都是真诚的。
Right, right.
对，对。
Yeah, I felt in something that I worked on, I feel the same way of just like, sure, of course you want people to like it and by extension, there's something about liking you.
是的，我在自己参与过的一些作品中也有同感，我也有同样的感受，就是：当然，你希望人们喜欢它，由此延伸开来，这也关乎到人们是否喜欢你。
And the, I did this film, and when people would come up to me afterwards, the speed with which I would deflect to, oh yeah, we did this.
我拍过一部电影，当人们事后来找我时，我转移话题的速度简直快得惊人：“哦对，我们大家一起做的。”
Oh yeah, the cast did this.
“哦对，演员们一起完成的。”
The group did this.
“团队一起做的。”
Just how fast can I get it away from me?
我能多快把功劳从自己身上撇开，就有多快。
Couldn't be faster.
绝对没有比这更快的了。
But of course, the person saying the tune, I think about myself, I don't really go up to too many people and say things.
但当然，说赞美之词的那个人……想想我自己，我其实不会主动去找太多人说那些话。
I got, I picked very carefully.
我……我挑得非常仔细。
I think complimented me in a while, Alec.
亚历克斯，我好久没听到别人夸我了。
It's in my head every day.
这句话每天都在我脑子里打转。
Yeah, I'd love to hear what you have to say.
对，我很想听听你要对我说什么。
Could you do it offline?
你能私下对我说吗？
你能私下说吗？
I don't wanna do it.
我不想公开来。
I'll be doing it.
我这就去私下说。
I'll email you.
我会发邮件给你。
But for a lot of people, also, the strength, the work, the preparation it takes to come up to someone and say, I loved you, I loved your work, is that takes a lot, I know we, yeah.
但对许多人来说，鼓起勇气走到一个人面前说“我喜欢你，我喜欢你的作品”，所需要的力量、努力和心理准备——这真的不容易，我知道我们，是的。
Well, I would also say for the person who asked, how do you become, how do you break into the business from the East Coast, if someone's work moves you, write them a fan letter, reach out to them.
嗯，我也想对那个提问的人说，你是怎么进入这个行业的，怎么从东海岸打入这个圈子的？如果某个人的作品打动了你，就写一封粉丝信给他，去联系他。
I've written fan letter, I mean, I'm in an advantaged position because people often know who I am, so it's like I can strike up an artistic kind of friendship kind of quickly by reaching out.
我写过粉丝信，我的意思是，我处于一个比较有利的位置，因为人们通常知道我是谁，所以通过主动联系，我能比较快地建立起一种艺术上的友谊。
But I genuinely like, when I love something, like that reminds me, we watched Chris Fleming's Stand up special on HBO last night.
但我真心觉得，当我喜欢某样东西时——这让我想起，我们昨晚在HBO上看克里斯·弗莱明的单口喜剧专场。
If you haven't seen it, it is one of the strangest wild, like he's such a visionary, strange alien of a stand up comedian.
如果你还没看过，那绝对是最古怪、最疯狂的节目之一，他就像是一个充满远见又怪异的单口喜剧外星人。
Yeah.
是的。
Chris Fleming on HBO.
克里斯·弗莱明，在HBO。
And I know him a little bit only through Instagram.
我其实不算真正认识他，只是通过Instagram有一点交集。
We've like DM'd a couple times.
我们私信过几次。
But I need to write him to tell him that we watched this last night and my wife and I were absolutely howling, you know?
但我得写信告诉他，我们昨晚看了这个，我和我太太简直笑得前仰后合，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So reach out when people's work moves you, let them know.
所以，当别人的作品打动你时，去联系他们，让他们知道。
means a lot.
这意义重大。
Yeah.
是的。
It's interesting what you said, but also when you put down your own work, what it says to the people who've seen it, I know Woody Allen is a very complex person in many ways, but this is someone who runs down every single one of his own movies.
你刚才说的话很有意思，但话说回来，当你贬低自己的作品时，这对那些看过的人来说意味着什么？我知道伍迪·艾伦在很多方面是一个非常复杂的人，但他就是那种会贬低自己每一部电影的人。
He truly has nothing good to say about his own work.
他真的说不出自己作品的一句好话。
And there is a feeling of, well, wait a second, I loved your work my whole whole, my whole life.
这就会给人一种感觉：等等，我一辈子、一整个童年都那么喜欢你的作品。
And when it's a constant stream of that was crap, that was crap, that was crap.
而当这种“那是垃圾，那是垃圾，那是垃圾”的言论滔滔不绝时。
There is a weird, it's dispiriting, yo.
这感觉很怪异，让人泄气，真的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
Okay, we've got time for two more questions.
好了，我们还有时间回答最后两个问题。
And here's one.
这是其中一个。
And we've talked about it, of course, on the show, but for new listeners, Abhi ABHI 25N asks, who came up with the idea for this podcast?
我们在节目里当然也讨论过这个，但对于新听众来说，Abhi ABHI 25N问：谁想出了做这个播客的主意？
I would say it was a kind of alley-oop between my wife and me and Craig.
我觉得这是我和我太太还有克里斯之间的一次默契配合。
So what happened was my wife had never seen the show, which I've said before was a great help in our courtship.
事情是这样的，我太太以前从没看过这部剧，我以前说过，这对我俩的追求过程非常有帮助。
Because I mean, sometimes you, if you realize people are fans of the show, you're like, who do you think you're dating right now?
因为有时候，如果你发现别人是这部剧的粉丝，你就会想：你现在觉得你在和谁约会呢？
Like, you know, you want there to be a clear distinction.
就像，你知道的，你希望界限能分得清清楚楚。
But she had never seen the show, which was great.
但她从没看过这部剧，这很棒。
But she came to me, I don't know, a couple of summers ago and said I would really like to see the show.
不过大概在几个夏天前，她来找我，说她真的很想看这部剧。
I missed this huge chapter of your life.
我错过了你生命中的一大块重要篇章。
I think I'll be able to be clear about who I married to versus who I'm watching on TV.
我想我能分得清我嫁的是谁，以及我在电视上看到的是谁。
And she said I'd love to watch it, so can we watch it?
她说她很想看，所以我们能一起看吗？
And then I thought, well, why don't, you know, it's enough time has passed and I called Craig kind of immediately and I said, Jordana wants to start watching the show, but why don't you and I, would you want to do something a little more formal and watch the show together and do a podcast and talk about it?
然后我想，嗯，为什么不呢？你知道的，已经过去足够长的时间了。我几乎立刻就给克里斯打了电话，我说乔丹娜想开始看这部剧了，但你我为什么不——你想不想搞得稍微正式一点，一起看这部剧，然后做个播客来聊聊它？
Because I also love Craig and always miss Craig and want to spend more time with Craig, but life takes over and we weren't seen as much of each other as I would have liked.
因为我也爱克里斯，总是很想念克里斯，想花更多时间陪克里斯，但生活总是被各种琐事占据，我们见面的次数没有我希望的那么多。
We immediately called Alec Lev, our producer who I'm talking to right now, and I don't know, by the end of the day, we're on the line with our agents and getting it all hammered out.
我们立刻给我们的制作人亚历克·莱夫打了电话——也就是我现在正在和他说的那个人。我不知道，到那天结束时，我们已经和经纪人们通上话，把这事敲定下来了。
weirdly fast.
快得有点诡异。
And then I came up very quickly.
然后这个名字很快就出来了。
I just said, what about how we made your mother?
我当时就说，叫《老爸老妈的浪漫史》制作过程怎么样？
And that was kind of the name.
名字差不多就是这么定下来的。
Like, it was all just very fast.
一切都发生得非常快。
Yes.
是的。
Okay.
好吧。
So to, I said two more now two more.
所以，我说还有两个，现在还剩两个。
This is more of a comment and it's lovely.
这更像是一个评论，而且非常可爱。
And it obviously goes to what you were saying that so many people have written in saying similar things.
这显然印证了你刚才所说的，有那么多人写信来表达类似的感受。我可以透露的是，我们刚刚录制的一期节目可能还没播出，现在先不说太多细节，但这是一集非常非常特别的节目，嘉宾是一位这部剧对他意义重大的观众，所以请大家留意一个非常特别的彩蛋集，那基本就是我们和一个剧迷在聊天。并且，Amid WV说我已经问过——我不确定他们之前问了什么——但我只是想说，我目前的生活正陷入低谷。
And I could say that it probably will not have aired yet that we just recorded won't say too much about it now but a very very very special episode with someone who watched the show that it meant a lot to them so so be on the lookout for a a very special bonus episode that's pretty much us talking to a fan of the show and and Amid WV says I already asked I'm not sure what they already asked but I just want to say that I'm struggling in my life at the moment.
所以我回头去重温这部剧，因为它真的能帮到我。
So I went back to watch the show because it really helps me.
我只想说非常感谢你，乔什。
I just want to say thank you so much, Josh.
我真的很感激你。
I really appreciate you.
哦，是的。
Oh yeah.
哇。
Wow.
这太棒了。
That's wonderful.
我很高兴你现在情况好转了。
I'm glad you're in a better place.
而且，你知道的，我前几天和杰西·泰勒·弗格森（曾出演《摩登家庭》）以及雷恩·威尔逊（《办公室》里的雷恩）有过这样的交流。
And I, you know, I've had these conversations with Jesse Tyler Ferguson, who was on Modern Family and RAINN the other day, RAINN Wilson from the office.
我们都一致认为，最特别的事情就是听到人们说：“我当时正经历一段非常艰难的时期，而你们的节目减轻了我的负担，感觉就像在黑暗时刻有一只手在握着我。”
And we both, we all agreed that the most special thing is to hear from people who said I was going through a really hard time, and your show lightened my burden, your show just kind of felt like it was holding my hand through the dark moment.
当你拍摄的时候，你根本不会意识到你的节目对某个人来说竟然有这种意义。
And you don't realize that your show might be that for someone when you're filming it.
但我很高兴能成为能够带给你这种力量的事物的一部分。
But I'm so glad to have been a part of something that can be that for you.
所以谢谢你让我知道这一切。
So thanks for letting me know.
最后，连续下划线ephemera问：扮演一个把生活讲成精心编排的故事的人……
And finally, continuous underscore ephemera asks, playing a man who tells his life as a carefully curated story.
……这是否会改变你对自己记忆的看法？究竟是我们书写了自己的人生，还是仅仅作为旁白试图在混乱中寻找逻辑？
to change how you think about your own memories, whether we're authors of our lives, or just narrators trying to make chaos coherent.
天哪。
Geez.
我知道，我总是抛给你……
I know, I always give you.
这是最后一个，我把这最后一个留到现在。
It's the last one, I hold on to that last one.
对，对，这是一个很好的问题。
Yeah, yeah, that's a great question.
你知道的，我写日记有时断有时续。
You know, I go in and out of journaling.
我前几天其实刚跟我太太提起这个，因为我儿子，那天早上我们和他在一起。
I actually said this to my wife the other day because my son, we were with him in the morning And I realized there was something that he used to do, that he's no longer doing.
我突然意识到他以前有个习惯，现在不做了。
I can't even remember what it was.
我甚至记不起那是什么习惯了。
But I said to her, I wish I had journaled more.
但我对她说，我真希望自己以前能多写写日记。
Like, I was too tired.
就好像，我当时太累了。
But I wish I had really journaled more so that we would just have more of a beyond the many, many pictures we've taken, just have more of a log of all these changes and document them.
但我真希望自己能多记点日记，这样除了拍过的许许多多照片之外，我们还能有更多关于这些变化的记录，把它们存档。
And I have a, I suppose a complicated relationship nostalgia because while I want to kind of catalog or look back at these different chapters of my life and look back with hopefully some fondness or realize the lessons I learned, there's also, you know, I'm a meditator and attempting to live a spiritual life which necessitates being in the present and not being so obsessed with the past and just being with what's right in front of me, which is this right now is the only thing that's happening.
而且我对于怀旧，我想有着一种复杂的感情。一方面，我很想把这些不同的人生篇章归档或回望，希望带着某种喜爱去回顾，或者认识到我所学到的教训；但另一方面，你知道的，我是一个冥想者，我正试图过一种精神层面的生活，这要求我们必须活在当下，不能过度执着于过去，只需和眼前的事物在一起——此时此刻，这就是唯一正在发生的事。
So I think there are pleasures to be had in looking backwards and there's also dangers to be had in looking backwards.
所以我觉得，回望过去有回望过去的乐趣，但回望过去也有回望过去的危险。
I think one of the things I'm writing a piece, co-writing a screenplay that's a lot about memory and the fallibility of memory and how I met your mother deals with that too where So Craig and I, we've talked about the podcast, like, is this, is what you're seeing, Ted, the narrator's version of it, or are we seeing the actual thing?
我想其中一件事是，我正在写一部作品，和别人合写一个电影剧本，里面有很多关于记忆、记忆不可靠的内容，正如《老爸老妈的浪漫史》也在探讨的那样——所以克里斯和我，我们一直在讨论这个播客，比如：你现在看到的这些，是叙述者泰德眼中的版本，还是我们看到的真实情况？
Like it's very confusing.
这真的很让人困惑。
I don't know.
我不知道。
That's for the chat room to figure out.
那就留给聊天室的观众去琢磨吧。
But I think that, you know, it's up to us to find meaning in what I think you said chaos.
但我认为，你知道的，我们要负责在——我想你刚才用了“混乱”这个词——中找到意义。
I don't actually believe it's chaos.
我其实不认为那是混乱。
I don't believe it's chaos.
我不相信那是混乱。
I believe that until we find meaning in it, it can present as chaos.
我相信，在我们为之赋予意义之前，它可能会呈现为混乱。
But once we find the meaning in it, and once we get the lesson, and once we have the TED-like 20, 25-year lens on things, I think a lot of people have had the experience of being incredibly lost or having a chapter that felt really dark and really hard.
但一旦我们在其中找到了意义，一旦我们吸取了教训，一旦我们拥有了像泰德那样历经20、25年的视角来看待事物，我想很多人都有过这样的经历：曾感到无比迷茫，或者经历过一段感觉极其黑暗、极其艰难的人生阶段。
And then the clouds part and something happens and you get to a place where you realize that your character was forged in that moment or you found a new kind of grit or resilience and you never would be at the quite wonderful place that life took you had you not journeyed through that dark wood.
然后乌云散开，某些事情发生了，你来到了这样一个人生阶段：你意识到你的性格就是在那个时刻被塑造的，或者你发现了一种全新的坚韧与弹性，而如果你没有走过那片黑暗的森林，人生绝不会把你带到如今这个如此美妙的地方。
There's something about our brain, this is what we've talking about about a brain.
我们的脑子里似乎有某种机制——这就是我们一直在讨论的大脑的某种特质。
There's something about our brains that want our lives to be struggle-free and that we just want to go from triumph to triumph.
我们的脑子里有一种倾向，希望生活是毫无挣扎的，只想从一个胜利走向另一个胜利。
And it's not, it yields nothing, like it's ridiculous.
但这根本行不通，毫无结果，简直荒谬。
If we did that, we would be quite shallow creatures and we would stop succeeding anyway because we would have nothing to talk about.
如果我们真那样做了，我们就会成为非常浅薄的生物，而且无论如何我们最终都会停止成功，因为我们无话可说了。
All this stuff is in the dirt, you know?
所有这些真正的干货都在泥土里，你知道吗？
It's when we, you know, I just read a thing about success and the shadow and hubris and all this stuff I was reading this morning.
就在我们——我今天早上刚读到一篇关于成功、阴暗面、傲慢以及诸如此类事情的文章。
And it said, you know, keep your eye on the next mountain you're going to climb, but make sure when you're in the valley, you learn the lessons of the valley.
上面说，盯紧你要攀登的下一座山，但确保身处山谷时，要汲取山谷里的教训。
It's interesting that you have forged a re-watch podcast that I think actually very much goes along with what you're saying here that this was never going to be from that first conversation, the one and only one that we needed to have to decide like you're going to do this.
很有意思的是，你打造了一个重温节目的播客，我觉得这实际上非常符合你在这里所说的话：从最初的对话开始，这就从来不是那种我们只需要进行一次、然后就能拍板决定“你必须做这个”的普通谈话。
The first conversation, you knew you weren't just going to talk about each scene that happened in the show.
在最初的对话中，你就知道你不会仅仅去聊剧中发生的每一个场景。
And I remember filming this.
我记得当时拍摄的情景。
You knew that you were going to connect it to being the person you are now, the age you are now, the actor, artist, father, husband that you are now, because there's looking back gives you, I guess, the purpose of looking back right is to give you some sort of perspective on where you are right now.
你知道你会把剧中的经历与现在的自己、现在的年龄，以及你现在作为演员、艺术家、父亲、丈夫的身份联系起来，因为回望过去赋予了你——我想回望过去的意义，不正是为了让你对当下的自己有一个某种程度的视角吗？
And so I think you have forged a rewatch podcast very much in line with that spiritual version of looking back at being present.
所以我觉得，你打造了一个非常符合那种精神内核的重温播客，既回望过去，又立足当下。
Yeah, I, you know, if you are interested in scene by scene breakdowns and talking about how certain jokes came up within the writer's room and why we chose that over that and the origin of the ducky tie, like that's all in this podcast.
是的，你知道的，如果你对逐集拆解、探讨某个笑话是如何在编剧室里诞生的、为什么我们选了这个而不是那个、以及“蓝色小号”或鸭子领带的起源感兴趣——所有这些都在这个播客里。
It's not all philosophy.
它并不全是阳春白雪的哲学。
And Craig and I really do like talking about who we are, who we were then, how the show changed us.
我和克里斯确实很喜欢谈论我们是谁、我们当时是谁、这部剧是如何改变我们的。
So we really do wade into these deeper waters and I think that's part of what the joy for a lot of people is for the show.
所以我们确实会涉足这些更深的水域，而我认为这正是许多人看这部剧的乐趣所在。
I mean, this is really like, it's like a, it's like a, if you want to get a PhD and how I met your mother, you should listen to how we made your mother.
我的意思是，这真的就像是，如果你想拿一个《老爸老妈浪漫史》的博士学位，你就应该听听《我们是如何制作老爸老妈浪漫史的》。
So thank you all for joining us here.
所以谢谢大家今天加入我们。
sure to follow, subscribe to our podcast, How We Made Your Mother.
请务必关注、订阅我们的播客《我们是如何制作老爸老妈浪漫史的》。
Go to HowWeMakeYourMother.com to follow there and tell you how we met your mother friends.
访问 HowWeMakeYourMother.com 在那里关注我们，并告诉那些没有来到现场的《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝们。
Please, who are not here today, who haven't given our podcast a try.
拜托，那些今天没来这里、还没尝试过我们播客的人。
And until next time, thank you so much.
直到下次，非常感谢。
Yeah, thanks for joining us.
是的，谢谢你们加入我们。
It was great to be with you.
很高兴能和大家在一起。
Im guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请宽恕我吧。
All sins are forgiven.
所有罪孽都被原谅了。
I knew York City."
我爱纽约市。"
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们是如何制作老爸老妈浪漫史的》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 呈现和分发。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西担任执行制片人。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matata.
节目由我，亚历克·莱夫制作和剪辑，我们的联合制片人是道格·马塔塔。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point to Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point to Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，也就是 Z 世代大师，是艾米丽·布伦伯格。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面艺术由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《纽约市》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供额外音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢罗拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的简报，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和所有其他内容。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel That's Not How It Happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
在各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的长篇小说处女作《事情可不是这样的》，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上查看他的其他出版作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“已故父亲协会”。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解更多关于如何为本节目旨在为先天性小儿心脏病研究筹集资金的持续活动做出贡献的信息，请查看我们网站顶部的“创造不同”标签。
people will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。